[Musik]
die ms europa 2 bei weitem nicht das
größte wohl aber eines der luxuriösesten
kreuzfahrtschiffe der netz wo immer der
luxusliner auftaucht ist ihm
aufmerksamkeit gewiss so wie hier bei
einer veranstaltung im hamburger hafen
das ganze jahr über ist die ms europa 2
unterwegs von der ostsee kreuzfahrt bis
zur mehrwöchigen atlantik reise vor
jeder neuen tour überprüft hotelmanager
johann schrenk ob alles seine ordnung
hat der österreicher ist chef von 280
der insgesamt 370 besatzungsmitglieder
auf seinem schiff soll nicht nur
luxuriös sondern vor allem auch
entspannt zugehen
bei uns gibt es nicht mehr dieses
klassische kapitänsdinner denen sonst
gewohnt ist oder den empfang sondern bei
uns ist das eher etwas schwerer
auch von der kleiderordnung her
516 passagiere haben auf der ms europa
sehr viel platz denn sie wohnen
ausschließlich inzwischen die beiden
größten sind mit die 115 quadratmetern
die sogenannten owners suiten
der preis wird nur auf anfrage genannt
größenordnung etwa zweieinhalbtausend
euro pro tag
[Musik]
am liebsten schaut der hotelmanager vor
der abfahrt noch einmal selbst nach dem
rechten und holen das bei uns relativ
schnell unter druck passieren müssen
da kann sein dass man etwas übersieht
dadurch gehe ich dann noch einmal
anschauen gerade in gewissen segmenten
ob das dann auch seine richtigkeit hat
oder nicht
[Musik]
farbakzente finden sich nur sparsam in
den dezent gehalten
die hamburger architekten kai bunge und
sieg für die kinder haben das komplette
innere des schiffes gestaltet die nun
wichtig dass alles auch so aussieht wie
sie es vor gegeben haben
es geht wirklich bis ins kleinste detail
muss muss ja muss muss und dass wir wenn
er vielleicht auch letzten endes nicht
jedes einzelne detail hundertprozentig
warnen direkt wahrnimmt aber er versteht
er empfindet die gesamtkomposition wie
stimmig ist kein luxus schiff ohne spa
bereich auch dieser ist und seine farben
auf die ausstattung des schiffes
abgestimmt und bietet viel platz innen
und außen das deck vier und der so
genannte öffentliche bereich hier gibt
es acht restaurants bars einen jazz club
und ein theater mit 418 flat letzte
vorbereitungen auch unterwegs das team
bekocht die gäste mit internationalen
spezialitäten etwa aus der italienischen
französischen oder japanischen küche
zeit für eine kleine pause für hotel
manager johann schwenn und dann geht es
los
die nächsten ziele der ms europa 2
nadine asien südeuropa die amerikanische
ostküste und die karibik